markiplier impossible normal finish
what's the extreme finish last one throw
excuse me Dario no you shall pay the
ultimate price why did you stab yourself
in your dick oh why do I have a
proclivity to stab people in the dick
sorry yeah haha I missed your ding dong
by that much Oh arrow fall I have no
idea I'm ill-prepared I'm the wrong
person oh I'm dead alright cool alright
try this on the probably more
appropriate segue gay album my botox
Alma face somehow I made it in pieces
but I made it down is five for a sarah
markiplier massacre oh you bastard keys
oh you bastards you're gonna pay for
whatever the hell you get to me I don't
even remember the halia did like so long
it's admin first to live up in the North
Pole
do you know how often that a story grows
nipples
oh forget Santa ever said that
markiplier obstacle yep Oh where's all
that blood coming yeah my ankles okay
take it again again we're all blood come
from sure ma but you go get it okay no
yeah finally I don't know where that
came from back oh so close okay
no thank you okay okay could I just you
know like not get all sassy pose my butt
is stronger than your poon no no no oh
my groaning okay Oh again with the but
oh my cankles fudge what slowed me down
there's a bunch of [ __ ] that's what
this is ow again okay no I'm still alive
ah thank you
giant ball you've always protected me
that's why I always loved you now I'm
dead but nobody we vote fell to Chamonix
France
Oh am I still alive I am
why damn it here we go
stop stop stop so I forgot I forgot
about those go go go go go go go go go
go go go go go go yeah I'm gonna win I'm
gonna win no matter what I'm gonna [ __ ]
I'm gonna win I'm gonna win no matter
what I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm going to win I'm
going to end them out of that one up
through my anus and hit me in my brain
[ __ ]
live [ __ ] why did I get so much air that
time I'm gonna get through this I'm
gonna get thro this holy [ __ ] oh my
god now [ __ ] [ __ ] of course that [ __ ]
chain is there of course why wouldn't it
be [ __ ] that's what the chains for it's
for not making you win this oh god this
is so stupid
this is so stupid [ __ ] come on
oh you think I'd get it from sheer luck
by now come on [ __ ] oh god what did I do
I [ __ ] control W you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] you piece up [ __ ] you
alright here we go again
god dammit don't [ __ ] up wow what did I
just say what why why oh I don't get
this I don't get the physics of it
doesn't frickin make sense [ __ ] God [ __ ]
I'm not stopping till I win this I'm not
stopping [ __ ] you
[ __ ] me and a nose well [ __ ] okay
Godfrey Godfrey Godfrey Godfrey
oh [ __ ] May every time I get to this
place where I could be good with the
timing it's [ __ ] over shouts I'd [ __ ]
you oh come on really really really
really really [ __ ] you oh god now I'm
dangling by my taint
oh I just want to win I just want to
beat this level Oh what the [ __ ] you
stop grabbing my deck god damn it why
can't I get the timing why can't I just
have one beautiful window where
everything doesn't [ __ ] with me I always
catch it always I always get it on the
downswing I never get an upswing and
when I do I do that
I [ __ ] go off a million miles in that
guy I'm going to kill everyone who had a
thought of making this god damn level
land in the winner's circle oh I am so
done I'm so done
[ __ ] just give me the right timing [ __ ]